this is a replicated Nursery my Nursery
my toys the dolls the crib the wallpaper
was redone replicated and put together
to do this exhibit in the rocking chairs
are all as was as is in my Nursery
upstairs I can tell you that doll I
recognized very well the wallpaper I do
remember very well it's been replicated
perfectly it still is upstairs in my
Nursery as we speak but it's a little
run down so they had to you know find it
get it copied get it remade so this is
an exact you know as close as can be
replica of the nursery that's still on
the top floor of Graceland
so here we have the faux the infamous
faux fake fur that I had everyone
thought I was so luxurious as a child
and there it is it's fake and um and
it's there and then here's the record
player my first record player which I
hadn't seen since yesterday since I was
Tiny I just remember being you know
having it in the middle of the floor and
playing records well you know I actually
like we have record players in our house
still to this day so I'm happy to see it
um I got one for Christmas with records
and vinyl and 45s so I'm excited when I
see record player because even my kids
love going to
um vintage record stores and getting
records so I'd love to bring the record
back
this is kind of the section where they
wanted to
show the charity aspect of what my
father was all about which he was
involved in many different charities and
these are some of the a lot of the Czech
City Road and they wanted to feature
that he almost you know gave quickly or
more quickly what he had than you know
he he probably gave more than he had
all of the memories here my favorite you
know my my golf cart key was a big one I
have to say I had my own golf cart that
my father gave me and it might the key
is kind of encapsulated in a box and
it's a key with a tag with my name on it
it's worn out completely and it was kind
of
my key to Terror Freedom you know
Mayhem that key was my life it was never
far from me or you know that was the
first thing I went for when I would
arrive at Graceland was where's my key I
hadn't seen the ID bracelet that he gave
me that was featured in a photo for
years we're always trying to find new
and interesting things to do in this
room and someone gave you know brought
up this idea of having this exhibit of
me and my father and I didn't quite know
what it would mean and um they you know
pulled together the most amazing things
and it's very interesting it's kind of
encapsulating my childhood in my life
which is you know emotional and
fascinating and interesting all in one
you want to celebrate someone who
pioneered music and who made such a
change in the world and historically and
uh speaking
changed everything and you want to you
know celebrate that kind of thing now I
don't think that it's something to
grieve it's overwhelming you know a
little bit it's like this is your life
and all in one room
[Music]